people are so crazy they they want you
to believe i don't have the energy to
exercise god damn it everyone does if
you're alive you can exercise i believe
that i've been there i know i'm a
different case but i've seen my dad
there and then here's the thing once he
fixed up his diet once he went to this
carnivore diet he's exercising now sure
he's got less weight on his body he
feels better and he has energy that's
wonderful he could have exercised then
too he would have felt sure for sure
wouldn't have felt as good as he's
feeling now but to give people this
excuse i don't have the energy to
exercise that is crazy to say can you
walk to the refrigerator yes well you
can exercise
you don't have to do anything crazy just
walk around the block there's a there's
80 year old ladies who take yoga with me
they're
really old and they're in there they're
going after it they could easily say i
don't have the energy to do that but
they don't it's a mental attitude they
make a decision